50 meters underwater just off the Greek
island of Antikythera lie the remains of
a merchant vessel that sank 2,000 years
ago it's one of the oldest and most
famous shipwrecks ever discovered when
divers returned to the wreck this summer
they found something incredibly rare
they had found a human skeleton that's
been buried under pottery shards and
sand for two millennia the bodies of
shipwreck victims are usually swept away
by ocean currents or eaten by fish so
this is an exciting find for
archaeologists they hope to learn more
about the people who traveled alongside
the ships rich cargo previously divers
have found bronze Spears
wine jars and most famously a
sophisticated clockwork device dubbed
the Antikythera mechanism using a tube
to suck up sediment the divers carefully
excavated there find a partial skull
with three teeth arm bones some rib
pieces and two femur the fragile bones
were transferred to ziplock bags full of
seawater before being brought to the
surface bone expert Hanna's Schroeder
was the first to examine them you know
there's those line creasing lines on top
like salt so kind of flaky probably from
the sediment there's iron concretions
off in office right which we're
suspecting it could be part of his gun
his or her garment the skeleton was
found next to pieces of corroded iron
perhaps clasps from the individuals
clothing or shackles for a slave you can
see red patches where the iron oxide has
stained the bones the skull also hints
at the individuals age probably mid 20s
because the bones are not fully knitted
together the teeth show little wear and
the two femurs or leg bones look fairly
robust so Hanna's guesses this was a
young man
but was he crew a rich passenger or even
a slave to learn more about him Hanna's
hopes to extract DNA from the skull a
skull that was underwater for 2,000
years this will push the boundaries of
ancient DNA analysis if it works we
could learn about his hair and eye color
diseases he might have inherited and
perhaps where he came from this could
help answer questions about the ship
itself it was sailing towards Rome when
it sank but archaeologists think it was
built in Greece and had a Greek crew if
the DNA analysis indicates that the
young man had Greek ancestry it would
add weight to this theory and another
piece in the story of this ancient
tragedy
you